Caos y destrucción tras una fuerte
jornada de lluvias récord que afectó el
norte del estado de Sao Paulo en Brasil
en especial en la ciudad de Sao
Sebastián durante el fin de semana de
carnaval provocando inundaciones y
deslizamientos de tierra el gobierno de
Sao Paulo decretó el estado de calamidad
pública por 180 días en las cinco
ciudades más afectadas y el presidente
Lula da Silva prometió una acción o
coordinada
puedo garantizar que mis ministros y el
gobernador están dispuestos a dialogar
para que podamos trabajar conjuntamente
para reparar de manera efectiva los
daños que la lluvia ha ocasionado aquí
en Sao Sebastián
las lluvias acumularon unos 600
milímetros superando el nivel que se
esperaba para todo el mes de febrero en
medio del carnaval además de los cientos
de personas que se vieron obligadas a
evacuar sus hogares muchos viajeros que
decidieron pasar sus vacaciones en la
región también tuvieron que evacuar
desastre por el que el gobierno ya ha
anunciado el desembolso de alrededor de
un millón y medio de dólares para las
tareas de rescate y reconstrucción
ayer no pudimos sacar nuestro auto Así
que está dañado y casi perdemos otras
cosas de dentro de casa
la situación está crítica sólo tenemos
una salida para ir hacia Sao Paulo está
todo inundado
estamos medio aislados aquí con ráfagas
de viento que marcaron hasta 55
kilómetros por hora el Instituto
Nacional de meteorología reportó que las
lluvias continuaran en la zona costera
del estado en los próximos días Lo que
podría agravar la